I've got whacked out video of Ron
DeSantis in Japan
shaking and smiling I don't know if
someone told him you've gotta look
cheerful and this is how he did it but
the guy's personality really leaves a
little something to be desired Ron
DeSantis was asked upon I guess Landing
in Japan
um what's the deal with like you're
losing every poll to Trump which is true
and DeSantis is visibly shaking
and it's very strange I don't believe
this is a medical event but people are
studying this like there's a Pruder film
suggesting it's a deep fake but it is
all too real look at this house
tonight I'm not I'm not a candidate so
we'll see if and when that changes yeah
really weird stuff I'm gonna play it for
you once more and it it is strange
strange stuff find that a trumpet
I'm not I'm not a candidate so we'll see
if if and when that changes okay no by
the way there's no belief that this is a
medical event it the Rhonda santis
doesn't have tardive dyskinesia or any
of these things we're not making fun of
medical conditions it seems as though
this is how he's been coached to be
upbeat to shake and smile like a um
horror clown like from a scary movie uh
I don't think this guy has what it takes
the latest polling continues to show
weak numbers for Des Sanctus a little
bit of a pop-up but basically still
between 23 and 24. uh the green line at
the bottom of your screen is the santis
the purple line at the top
is uh Trump still between 52 and 53
DeSantis or Des Sanctus or de
sanctimonious between 23 and 24 and the
this 50 number is a very important thing
if you're Ron DeSantis and you're
thinking about do I run do I not run
if Trump already has 53 percent
you could get all of the non-trump vote
over to yourself and you still wouldn't
have enough right you could pick up
Pence's four and Haley's four and Tim
Scott's 1.6 and Rama Swami's 1.4 you
could get all of that and you'd still
only have 47. so you know there's a
period of six weeks ago I would have
said DeSantis isn't going to be able to
get away from running he's going to run
I'm not so sure now I'm not so sure it
may actually not make sense for him to
get involved in this and if that's the
case Trump runs away with this thing the
argument for DeSantis to get involved
would be even if Trump already has 50
percent
you need to be there visible and holding
25 percent
in case Trump gets arrested again in
case Trump gets indicted again in case
it becomes clear Trump can't possibly
run a campaign amidst the chaos of one
two or three different indictments you
need to be there with 25 percent to then
pick up some of Trump's support if and
when it becomes clear Trump simply can't
do this that's the best argument for
DeSantis because the numbers right now
show a DeSantis that can't possibly win
one of our sponsors is electric e-bikes
I've been watching e-bike reviews on
YouTube for a while because I've been
thinking of getting one and I
continually come across electric as the
brand to go with if your budget is
between 800 and 1300 and I have to agree
from experience I've had my electric
e-bike for a little while now I've
almost ditched my car and regularly bike
at this point for errands and things
around my neighborhood it's awesome
cardio because I'm still pedaling I get
there faster I can see more I'm reducing
my carbon footprint the e-bike came to
my doorstep fully assembled it has a
bright LCD screen seven speed gearing
five levels of pedal assist a powerful
battery that you can take inside to
charge it's also fully foldable I can
put it in the back of my car electric
has models for every lifestyle and you
can Finance for as little as 73 bucks a
month go to electricebikes.com to learn
more explore all of the incredible
e-bike models they offer the link is
down below